bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
hat dem schauspieler ulrich matthes am
dienstag das verdienstkreuz erster
klasse verliehen in seiner rede würdigte
steinmeier den 62 jährigen berliner als
engagierten staatsbürger und immer
wieder überraschenden schauspieler
thomas bernhard hat manchen seiner texte
untertitel gegeben wie etwa holz fällen
eine erregung oder
auslöschung ein zerfall
würde er würde bernhard noch leben
wm mit sicherheit schon an einem neuen
stück
mattes eine ermutigung
gerade gestern abend durfte ich sie
lieber mattes noch einmal in marias
menschenfeind sehen in der rolle des als
es zu sagen sie ins publikum
was sich im leben vollbracht dafür wird
kein staat mich ehren wir alle lieber
mattes sind da ganz andere auffassung
der neben familie und freunden des
geehrten war auch die ehemalige
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel unter den
gästen im schloss bellevue
medienberichten zufolge verbindet merkel
und mattes eine langjährige
bekanntschaft die frühere kanzlerin war
zuletzt nur noch selten in der
öffentlichkeit zu sehen
mattes gehört zum festen
schauspielerensemble am deutschen
theater in berlin er ist aber auch immer
wieder in tv und film rollen zu sehen
von 2009/10 bis 2022 war er zudem
präsident der deutschen filmakademie